as we seem to be discussing serpent-like
dragon creatures within mythology I
guess it's a good time to travel to the
Norse world and take a look at nidhogg
unlike Ladin nidhogg is certainly not a
protector quite the opposite to be
honest the name translates to mean
malice striker or he who strikes with
malice the Vikings used the word to
refer to someone who had lost their
honor and who had obtained the status of
villain so why does nidhogg have this
status within norse mythology
well if we go by what's in the prose
edda then it's mostly due to the fact
that nidhogg can be found at the bottom
of aggressive the world tree chewing and
gnawing away at its roots the world tree
is where all the nine realms and the
norse cosmos can be found if the tree
falls then the cosmos will fall back
into chaos there is also the idea that
the roots of the war tree are actually
keeping the serpent wrapped like a
prison
but when Ragnarok comes it will break
free other than trying to destroy the
only thing holding the universe together
nidhogg is mentioned a few more times in
relation to how nidhogg was seen by the
Vikings it was a dragon found in Hell a
part of the underworld known as Nestor
on the shore of corpses this is where
many of those responsible for the worst
and most heinous crimes would end up
once they washed up on the shores their
nightmares only really just began as net
hog devours their corpses as punishment
the other story net augur piercing can
be found in the poetic Edda and it also
involves ratatoskr and the wise eagle
now we know that nidhogg resides at the
bottom of the world tree but at the very
top is the wise eagle now these two
absolutely despise each other and that's
because of our crafty little friend
ratatoskr the messenger of the gods
when ratatoskr isn't delivering messages
he enjoys nothing more than running up
and down the wild tree spouting lies
between nidhogg and the
cool making up insults that the other
supposedly said pretty much trying to
start as much trouble as possible
one day natok found these insults to be
so offensive that he vowed he would kill
the eagle and in his anger he shook the
foundations of the tree so hard that the
entirety of the nine worlds trembled the
shaking of Yggdrasil and nidhogg being
set free from its roots are what many
considered to be two of the many signs
of ragnarok for those of you wanting to
know whether nidhogg was a serpent or a
dragon it's depicted as both and it's
commonplace in many cultures to see
dragons and serpents depicted as very
similar if not the same if you have any
thoughts or opinions that you'd like to
share then feel free to do so in the
comments below if you have enjoyed this
video then please consider leaving a
thumbs up as it really does help me and
the channel as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]